welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and I think we all need a full
account of the TVA from the Loki series
like Episode by episode throughout
seasons one and two we were kind of
given a different understanding of what
its purpose is how the agency was
created who was really in charge but now
that some time has passed since the
finale I think we finally have some
clarity on what he remains was really
planning throughout this whole season so
I'm going to break it down and really it
starts with two questions what was ob's
actual role in all of this and why when
Loki was first pushed out of the Citadel
in the season 1 finale did he
immediately time slip back to an earlier
era of the TVA before the timekeepers by
the way if you seeing less of me on the
channel this month it's because I have
gone on paternity leag my baby might be
arriving a bit sooner than expected so
we're playing it safe Jessica Clemens is
back to cover for me thanks Jessica and
thanks to everyone of the new rock star
team who's going to be stepping up this
month popping up in videos doing me a
huge solid and I appreciate the full new
rock star team I'm going to be back in a
few weeks but I'm just so excited to
watch their videos with baby boss okay
throughout Loki season 2 we wondered
whether it was he remains or Victor
timley or OB or someone else who
originally created the TVA the Loki
finale leaves it still a bit murky but
according to he remains it was still he
who paved everything and that includes
every step of the way that Loki took in
season 2 when Loki circles back to he
remains in the Citadel he remains
indicates that everything he went
through in season 2 was also part of his
design this isn't the first time we've
had this conversation how did you know I
know about the slipping and who do you
think paved that road He Who Minds bingo
so he taunts Loki saying Loki thought he
was slipping Through Time sticking it to
the system going to beat the man but
then whoop here he is and he asks did
you really think I was going to sit back
and let her kill me so really everything
that he remains did this season is just
because he didn't want to have to deal
with Sylvie that Sylvie was someone who
would not negotiate maybe Loki would be
more willing to hear him out and he
remains indicates that he also knows all
about Victor timley in this supposed
scaling problem of the temporal Loom
that seemed to be the major crisis of
this season no there's no there's no
problem the temporal Loom
is a fail safe it deletes the ones that
aren't supposed to be there everything
except the sacred timeline and the TVA
well that's just that's just collateral
damage no Big Easy to rebuild so this
line really says it all he remains
created the TVA the story that he told
in season 1 that he used elath to prune
all the other timelines to win the
multiversal war to build the TVA that
was all true but what he left out was
Ren Slayer Ren Slayer helped him tame
goath helped him win the mersal war and
shortly after that he used protocol 42
to wipe her memory and just make her
kind of like a minute man Hunter of the
TVA and then later on a judge but he
built this apparatus of a loom to kind
of automatically prune the sacred
timeline into one braided Strand and
that Loom has in it a fail save so that
if ever gets overloaded which it does
from time to time to time it
automatically just prunes everything so
you don't have to rely on the
professionalism of the TVA Workforce the
TVA melts down everyone in dies and
spaghetti fies and then it just gets
rebuilt over and over and over again and
he remains oversees it all sitting in a
chair by himself in the Citadel just
twiddling his thumbs and when it comes
to the season one finale leading into
this season the implication really is
that he remains sent Miss minutes and gr
Slayer to deliver a TVA handbook to
Victor timley in 1868 Chicago so that
Victor timley in 1893 would be a
chicago-based inventor n kind of con man
who did a lot of writings but an
inventor way ahead of his time whose
writings would inspire people like a
Caltech theoretical physics Professor
turned science fiction writer ad Doug
and when OB in the TVA meets Victor
timely the two geek out over each other
you wrote the TVA handbook but I learned
everything I know from a brilliant 19
century inventor n Victor timely so if
your work is based on his work and his
work is based on your work exactly which
came first it's like a Snak eating its
own tail so we get this little pocket
Paradox as I'm going to call it and this
was deliberately created to be a
self-contained Ora Boris a snake eating
its own tail and that's why Obie has
this name he remains upon his death from
sylv stab had in place a plan to Launch
launch a variant Victor timley on a road
that he paved to inspire OB for these
two to meet and for this little oror to
be just a little kind of distracting
tornado in the TVA to just caused
everyone to scramble over the temporal
Loom meltdown when really it was never
that much of a risk to the TVA because
the TBA could always be rebuilt this was
just designed to do one thing to
manipulate Loki into learning how to
control time slipping so that Loki could
make it back to he remains in the
Citadel and that these two men could
talk without the pesky Sylvie
interfering thank you you to better help
for sponsoring this video you can love
holiday season and also admit that it's
stressful travel time with family
marking time with New Years it can be a
lot and if you feel like you could use a
little help with it all try connecting
with a licensed therapist by using
better help starting therapy can be hard
the right therapist for you may not be
in your area and some people struggle
with the face-to-face interaction of
therapy with better help you can have
your therapy sessions as a phone call as
a video chat even via messaging if you
prefer that whatever is the most
comfortable version of therapy for you
just click the the link in the
description and answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for no additional cost
without stressing about insurance who's
in your network or anything like that if
you think that you might benefit from
therapy consider betterhelp click the
link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com neww rockstars clicking
that link helps support this Channel and
also gets you 10% off your first month
of Better Health so that you can connect
with a therapist and see if helps you
now why when Sylvie pushed Loki out of
the Citadel in the season one finale did
he go back to an earlier era of the TVA
before the timekeepers when the agency
statues showed he remains appearance
like we did not see Loki's body time
slip physically you know like where his
limbs kind of turn into stretchy gross
bubble gum and his face contorts around
that did not happen when he fell through
the door so he didn't time slip he was
placed here Sylvie didn't do it she was
just using H M's temp pad H M's temp pad
was rigged and preset so that when
Sylvie used it to push Loki through the
door Loki would fall into that earlier
era why did he remain set it that way
because he wanted to initiate Loki's
time slipping glitch he cursed him so
that he would be time slipping he would
give Loki this hurdle to overcome but
more importantly a new skill to use a
way back to him so that Loki can
cognitively just kind of think and
unstick himself from time and loop back
earlier to his life path and find his
way back to the Citadel he also I think
did this because he wanted to take Loki
back to an earlier era where there was
some other past temporal Loom crisis
underway to show him that temporal Loom
meltdowns are a recurring thing in the
TVA so that when he tells this to Loki
later on Loki will believe him now of
course when they end up talking in the
Citadel Loki surprises he remains with
his own new power status he quotes a TS
Elliott poem that he remains doesn't
recognize and he kind of turns the
tables on he remains to declare himself
more in control of pausing Time and Time
slipping than he remains expected him to
be and I think right here is something
we have to recognize that I don't think
we've really talked about Loki figured
out how to time slip organically with
just his body and mind he who remains
cannot do that he needs technology ology
he needs that Master temp pad without it
I don't think he could pause time and
Rewind and loop things as well as he can
so why can Loki do it and he remains
can't well because he remains at the end
of the day is just a man Loki is a God
he was the god of Mischief now he's a
god of stories his body can resist the
flow of time because ASG Guardians and
frost Giants age slower than the humans
of Earth do so by teaching Loki time
slipping just because he remains
couldn't convince Sylvia of his argument
he remains made a huge mistake he gave a
god the powers he himself can only
achieve through technological Wizardry
now the only things that separate these
two are knowledge and resolve Loki gains
knowledge in the scene he looks at he
remains equations on the chalkboard and
realizes that he can build a more
functional Loom and Loki gains resolve
by having final conversations with
Mobius and Sylvie before he makes a
final walk toward the core so as we head
into Avengers Kang Dynasty he remains
Legacy will not be the Kang variant who
remained who cleverly tamed aath and
vanquished all other kings by pruning
their timelines he remains is going to
be known among the dynasty as the Kang
who made the greatest mistake that any
Kang has ever made he gave the the
opposition the powers that only kangs
are supposed to have and he gave the
Avengers a loophole into defeating the
Kang Dynasty all the Avengers are going
to have to do is aligned with someone
that most of them have only known as a
monster so I want to know from you what
do you think about this Theory comment
down below and reminder that it is ho ho
ho season at new rockstars so support us
by grabbing one of those holiday designs
from nerd. shop I'm going to be back for
my paternity leave in just a few weeks
big thanks to Jessica Clemens and the
whole new Rockstar team for covering for
me thanks for watching and I'll see you
soon
bye
[Music]
n